i love tomatoes from my head to my toes
these tomatoes are all chopped up now
because i'm making a delicious salad
do you like salad
whenever i make this salad i use
this recipe
the colorful building blocks make sure i
don't forget anything have a look
first i need something red
which are the
tomatoes then i need something green
which are the cucumbers
then black
for yummy olives
and now i need something white
which is the feta cheese
hi matt hi eddie what are you doing i'm
making a delicious greek salad using my
block recipe interesting how does it
work oh well i can show you
okay first we need something red
which is the tomatoes
so in they go to the jar
yummy
red
fresh
juicy
tomato this is gonna be so
lots and lots of tomatoes and then after
red
green for cucumbers
lots of round green fresh
cucumbers into the jar as well it's
gonna be very healthy yeah
there we go lots of green cucumbers
now
we need something
white is it white
oh black for the olives
so they go into the jar as well
i love all those i love them too
yum yum yum yum yum
there we go and finally we need
something red on top no was it black no
we just did black
oh i should use the recipe
white for feta cheese
on top
lots of yummy feta cheese it's all
complete nearly done wow there we go
last bit of feta in
there a delicious salad
yum how fun is maths what
this is maths i thought we were just
cooking well your recipe is maths see
it's a pattern the recipe's colors match
the salad you've just made an algorithm
an alga what an algorithm it's a
step-by-step way to get something done
so my recipe was an algorithm a
step-by-step way to make a salad exactly
thank you for coming to play school
today eddie you're so welcome matt shall
we have some salad please
thank you